let's hear from some more people of
course we do this on the Friday show you
can follow uh you can uh talk to me as I
guess is what I'm saying by uh signing
up for the Discord at
davidpackman.com
Discord let's go next to Kevin from
Philly Kevin from Philly welcome to the
program what's on your mind today
Kevin from Philly you've got to accept
my invitation my friend
there he is Kevin welcome
hi
um I was just wondering you know we've
heard recently more stories from Donald
Trump with grown men with tears in their
eyes yeah the latest one is like that
DeSantis came to him crying about an
endorsement
right do you think it's at least
possible that Trump maybe just wears too
much cologne or has very bad breath and
that's why the young men constantly have
tears in their eyes but it's just listen
order issue I'm as confused as you are
as to why grown men are regularly
bursting into tears around Donald Trump
and maybe you're right that it's like a
cologne type thing maybe it's a bad
breath thing honestly though I think the
most likely scenario is Trump's just
making it up
all right agree to disagree you
genuinely think people are crying but
you want to find the reason why
I don't know we'll see do you believe
for a second that DeSantis cried in
front of trump
no of course not I don't either it just
doesn't I don't think the conversation
happens no you will I know I mean I well
that's a good question did DeSantis ask
Trump friend I mean maybe the
endorsement request was made through
intermediaries it seems reasonable
DeSantis would ask for an endorsement
yeah I do wonder if if the primary does
come down to them there was this
commercial where DeSantis like was
reading a book about the wall and Trump
to his child and it's just this this
sycophantic suck up commercial to Trump
and it would be so interesting if that
popped back up if it was a primary
between them just to show like how like
subservient Ron DeSantis was to Trump
I'm gonna look for that that sounds
interesting I'm gonna also a few years
ago Ron DeSantis pronounced his name Ron
D santis which I find strange to change
how you say your name at age 40.
I think that should make a comeback
DeSantis yeah all right Kevin from
Philly appreciate the call
thanks all right there he goes